ان نتحدث عن المنتخب الفرنسي حامل اللقب
الذي يدخل هذه المنافسه للدفاع عن لقبه
لكن منقوص ان صح همم
لعنه حامل اللقب اذا صحه العباره ليس
المنتخب الفرنسي فحسب الذي يعاني من مثل
هذا هذه اللعنه هي رافقه المنتخب الفرنسي
بعد الفوز بمونديال 98
والخروج من الدوري الاول في 2002 هي
الاعلى المنتخب الالماني بعد التتويج بلقب
همم 2014 والخروج من الدوري الاول في
مونديال روسيا هي ليست المره الاولى لكن
همم نعم المنتخب الاسباني هي اكثر من
المنتخب لكن ما اردت تعقيب عليه هي لعنه
الاصابات تحدث عن الجدل فيما يخص المستوى
السياسي في ما يخص عده نقط لكن عندما
نتحدث رياضيا هناك همم جدل اخر يتواجد وهو
ان تقام هذه النسخه في مثل هذه الفتره همم
في مثل هذه الفتره هناك عدد هائل لقاءات
منذ شهرين تقريبا بمعدل ثلاث مباراه كل
ثلاثه ايام هذا المعدل رهيب هو سبب اصابه
اعتقد انها سبب اصابه كريم بنزيما هو
العدد المهول من اللقاءات التي كان اجرها
مع فريقه ريال مدريد وصل الى المونديال
باصابه طفيفه تعافى من الاصابه ويصاب في
جهه اخرى هذا الامر يعني مهم ومهم للغايه
وليس فقط كريم بنزيما هناك احاديث هناك
ليونيل ميسي يتدرب على انفراد ان كان مصاب
او يعاني من اصابته في هذا الامر اخر يعني
همم في الاخير اللاعب يبقى انسان اللاعب
هو يعني لا يمكنه ليس بال- بالاله لا
يمكنه الالعاب الالعاب على نطاق عالمي
ونطاق عالي بمعدل ثلاث ايام مباراه من
الحج الكبير
هناك
شهر فقط ليست تلك الراحه ايضا هم يخرجوا
من الصيف في موسم يرتاحون قليلا ما في
راحه يا هادي هؤلاء لاعبين يعني همم لا
مجموعه من اللاعبين يقبضون
النساء فقط
بانها ادم لا انتقد اتحدث عن جد الى
اللقاء عندما نتحدث عن القراءه
دوري ابطال اوروبا في شهر مايو شهر خمسه
واللقاءات تنطلق في شهر هناك على الاقل
على الاقل قبل انطلاق هناك فريق دوري
ابطال وهناك على الاقل شهر تحضيرات هذا
الجدول الزمني اثاره اكثر من مره المدرب
المنتخب الهولندي ان تقام مثل هذه
اللقاءات ونعلم جيدا لان هذا الموديل ياتي
بعد فتره خارجه اخرى فتره اثبت كوفي 19
واللعب يعني
امر واقع هذا الحديث في ما يخص يعني
الواقع الرياضي
الينا الان من الدوحه الخاص عثمان اهلا بك
معنا كنا في حديث همم ربما هنا في
الاستديو عثمان عن همم توقيت اقامه هذا
المنجال والاصابات ربما جدول المباريات
المكث الذي اثر على اللاعبين وادى الى بعض
الاصابات منها اصابه كريم بن زيمه الذي
همم لن يتم استبداله في المنتخب الفرنسي
وفق مقال جديد ديشون همم اليوم همم عثمان
هل تحدثت مثلا الى مشجعين فرنسيين هناك في
قطر وطلبت رايهم بنسبه لما حدثني
مساء الخير جميعا مساء الخير المشاهدين
اذن خيبه الامل كانت كبيره دنيا كيف لا
وهذا اللاعب هو الافضل في العالم هو صاحب
الكره الذهبيه همم كان قد غادر همم الحصه
التدريبيه مباشره الى احد المستشفيات حيث
خضع للعلاج وبطلب علاج الام الذي كشف على
انه مصاب على مستوى العضلات في الفخذ
الايسر وبالتالي همم الشفاء الكامل يبقى
بعد ثلاث اسابيع على الاقل وبالتالي سيغيب
بصفه رسميه خيبه امل كبيره لدى الفرنسيين
الذين كانوا يريدون ان يريدون بطالهم
والنجمهم كان بنزيما الفريق الى ابعد حد
ممكن ولما لا ربما الاطاحه بال ما يحدث
عاده لصاحب اللقب الذي عاده ما يخرج في
الدور الاول او لا يذهب بعيدا ولم يستطع
اي منتخب للحفاظ على لقبه الى منتخبان
منتخبين فقط هو المنتخب الايطالي عام 88
وايضا المنتخب البرازيلي عام 2-60
بعوده الى بما حديثكم عن الاصابات الواضح
ان لاعبي كره القدم في هذه الفتره بالذات
ربما يتعرض يتعرضون لاصابات كثيره
وبالتالي ربما الان ال- ال- يعني تعود
اصابات في هذه الفتره ليس سببه المونديال
ولكن ربما بعد العوده من المونديال
واللاعب الذي يصل الى النهائي سيجدو نفسه
بما يلعب حوالي همم 50 الى 60 مباراه همم
في همم الموسم وهذا كثير وكثير جدا
بشهادته
المختصين على كل الواضح عن القدماء
الالهيه في صالح المنظمين وفي صالح قطر
لان الحراره اليوم وعلى عكس العاده ليست
مرتفعه تماما ان الرياح طفيفه بارده
ستساعد ومن دون شيك على تقديم اداء افضل
فوق الميدان ومن دون شكل سوف لن تستخدم
المبردات همم الاصطناعيه